FRANCOIS SAULNIER:
Hi, everybody.
I'm full so Sony
MATHIEU LORBER: I'm Mathieu.
FRANCOIS SAULNIER: We
are coming from France.
We are the co-founders with
Eric Therond, who's there
in the audience, of Instill.
And we are going to talk about
how we built Instill with Dart.
So Instill is an online
service, with one you can build,
we can create--
MATHIEU LORBER: That's perfect.
FRANCOIS SAULNIER: With one you
can create informative videos.
So before Mathieu talks to you
about technical architecture
evolution, and how we moved
from Angular to Polymer--
and why we move from
Angular to Polymer--
I will talk to you about who
we are and what Instill is.
So we are three developers
with a strong background
in development and web
application development.
And a long time ago,
far away from here
in France, we used Java
stacks with MVC frameworks
like Struts or Spring
MVC, with piece of JS.,
and then, Prototype
and then jQuery
and all the frameworks you
can have in JavaScript.
And in 2008, we started building
large, single-page applications
with Squid and we had also
some experience with Flex.
So one year ago, we
were discussing video
and we observed that
video traffic was always
increasing on the internet.
And that people were consuming
more and more videos, even
in their work, to
share information
to make some presentations.
But at the same
time, we also noticed
that people were impedimented
in such video production
because it was time consuming.
So as we didn't find any tools
or services on the internet
to produce videos-- to be
efficient to produce videos--
we decided to create Instill.
So Instill is an
online service with one
you don't have to
consider technical video
stuff like
audiosynchronizations,
transitions, animations,
and other things.
So how it works--
it's quite simple.
Instill helps you to
structure your information.
And then to choose
visual representations
to illustrate what you
want to explain to people.
And then it helps you to record
your voice over the video.
So if you have an
idea, in one hour,
you can produce a
short video to explain
what you want to explain to
people-- the information you
want to share with people.
So I have a short
video demonstration
of how Instill works
that I will command.
So when you to create
a project with Instill,
we start by collecting
some information
like the title of the video,
the main objectives you want
to-- the information that people
will use after the main points,
so the structure
of the information.
And at the end of this
step, you've got a review.
And this review allows you to
check that you didn't forget
anything you wanted to build.
Then, you can immediately
have a preview
of the video at this stage.
So it's a preview--
it's not video.
It's rendered right
in the browser.
So it's based only on the
information you gave to us.
And after that, I can add a new
visual sequence to my video.
So I add an item list
to explain who we are.
So we are three
software engineers.
Where is Mathieu?
There.
Eric and myself.
So we can have an
instant preview
to check that the video is
OK and to see the animation.
And after that, we are
ready to record our voice.
So we have to accept the
microphone authorization
request.
And then when you click
on the Record button,
we can record the
voice over the video.
And we control the animation
flow by the next button.
So the device is the main way
to control the video flow--
the animation flow.
And then you can just publish
your video directly on YouTube,
or you can get a download link.
OK.
So why did we choose Dart?
It's all about productivity.
One year ago, Mathieu--
there-- told us, hey
guys, why don't we
start with Dart?
And maybe because
they call me papa--
so they call me daddy, in
English-- maybe because I'm
older than they are,
or maybe because I'm
an old fashioned guy-- I
don't know-- I say, no guys,
we don't start with this Dart.
We start with the
technologies we know
and where we are
already productive.
And after a long discussion
with Mathieu and Eric,
I admitted that
maybe I was wrong.
And I was wrong.
So we agreed that Dart
presented all the advantages
of the technologies we knew.
And we decided to
start with Dart.
So we started with
this technology.
And at the beginning,
we were very productive
but we reached some
limitations with the first UI
framework we chose.
So that's what Mathieu
is going to talk about.
MATHIEU LORBER: So
first, a quick overview
of the global
architecture of Instill.
So Instill is a single-page
application made with Dart.
We have a Java back end, so
the application is loaded once.
And then only JSON information
is shared with the back end.
As we render movies,
we can't render movie
in the lifetime of
an HTTP request,
so we have a message queue.
And the whole application
is asynchronous
because we have another
Java application, which
render in publishing movies.
And later, we hoped we'd be able
to connect directly the message
queue to the Dart
front end, so we
can give real time information
to the user about rendering
and publishing.
As you can see, we
kept a Java back end
because we were OK
with the back end.
Our stack is very lightweight.
The whole stack is great.
But truth is, when you
come back from Dart code,
Java is becoming to
be a bit painful.
Let's talk about the back end.
We have a CQRS and
Event-sourced back end.
CQRS stands for Command Query
Responsibility Segregation.
I'll be short-- the
main idea behind
is that design button is
separating write and read
responsibilities.
In our case, that's
the way we communicate
between the front
end and the back end.
We have a query base
and a command base.
And for example, when they need
a project in the front end,
I will send GetProjectQuery
to the back end.
The meaning is even
stronger than epicycles.
And when I have
an action-- which
would require a
write as a database--
I will send the
ChangeTitleCommand,
for example, to change a title.
Event-sourced means we
don't save whole objects
in the database.
When the user changes the
title of his presentation,
we don't save a new
presentation object.
We save a TitleChangedEvent.
So that's, as a reminder, a
typical screen of Instill.
So as in 99.7% of
web applications,
you can see we have forms.
But we have to make real
time pre-authorization--
we say preview in the rest
of the implementation.
We use [INAUDIBLE] canvas,
audio elements, video elements
and that makes a lot
of asynchronous code.
So asynchronous generators
are working for us.
But we also used
the [INAUDIBLE] API.
And that's a fun API
because it changed a lot
in the last months.
But through the API, we needed
to record the people's voice.
So that was important for us,
even if it was very unstable.
So we started the
application one year ago,
and we needed a framework for
the interface at that moment.
And AngularDart was
the natural choice.
It was a more mature framework
for interfaces at the moment.
And we felt very productive
in the first weeks.
We felt very productive
because of the data binding
and everything.
But we actually quickly
reached some difficulties.
I'm going to talk
about them now.
In the rest of the
presentation, I
will use the very complicated
component as an example.
That's the player.
We have the preview part,
a time indication, the play
and the stop button.
And I'm going to compose it.
So we have the player
at the top-- which
is the whole component-- with
two subcomponents, a control
panel, and a renderer.
The control panel is
composed of two buttons.
The timing indication
and the renderer
use the canvas and
video elements.
So this composition
may be simpler,
but this was the purpose
of the presentation.
With Angular, one good
way to code that component
would be to have a
PlayerAPI object, living
beside the components.
So the PlayerAPI is
binding to the player
and could be used
in the controllers.
I'm going to code
two whole components.
I have a movie in the PlayerAPI,
on which I make the binding.
I have play and stop methods,
who can be called directly
by the buttons.
And when I call
the play method--
and we have a play
event, which will
be handled by the renderer.
So that's OK.
But we actually have
two problems with that.
First, the renderer--
we want to reel it.
As you saw in the
screen, we have
lots of preview thumbnails.
And the renderer
subcomponent should
be used in those thumbnails.
And truth is, AngularDart
1 made the creation
of isolated, tiny
components very complicated.
Because in that case, I can't
really isolate my renderer.
The other problem we
had with that code
is that play and stop
events-- they weren't events.
They actually were orders.
And it wouldn't be a problem
if it was only that component.
But we had lots
and lots of events
which actually were orders.
And the code became
complicated because of that.
And let me tell the complete
story of a user action.
So I have my user.
It's a girl.
And her name is Natasha.
Natasha wants to change the
title of her presentation.
So she had an input,
she changed the title.
The browser fired
a changed event.
That change event is
handled by AngularDart.
We don't see it.
And AngularDart
operates binding.
So I have my project object.
It's title will be changed.
I will detect the change in
the object in our controller.
Our controller will create a
changed title command, which
will be sent to the back end.
And the back end will
save a TitleChangedEvent
in the database.
So here, Natasha--
if she could see
the whole journey--
she may wonder,
was it the simplest way?
Guys-- really.
Is it the simplest architecture,
with the data binding
and stuff?
To transform a changed
event from the browser
to a TitleChangedEvent
in the back end?
So that wasn't
technically complicated,
but it doesn't feel right.
We have other examples
of difficulties.
For example, when you add a
visual in your presentation,
we have an editor, which depends
on the kind of visual you use.
And with Angular, the only
way to switch the editor,
depending on the kind of
visual, was a big switch.
That's OK when you have
seven kinds of visuals.
But when you have 20,
it becomes complicated.
And we wanted to
programmatically add
those components.
And the only way to do it really
programmatically with Angular
was to use the internal
technical cases
of the frameworks.
So that wasn't good.
Another example was about
synchronous control.
Because we have video and sound.
We want them to be
really synchronous.
If we use the scope
and states, we
would have used the dirty
checking internal mechanism
of the scope.
And if you don't know
about dirty checking,
just know it's by nature--
it can be synchronous.
So we had a state-- we had a
state which cannot really be
watched, because the watch
this time wasn't synchronous.
So we had events for saying,
hey, pre-synchronously check
the state.
And it was complicated.
To be fair, AngularDart was
very good at some tasks.
Data binding is really great.
And Angular is the first really
good data centric framework.
But the component model
wasn't the one we needed.
So eight months ago, we
started to watch for Polymer
and check that its model--
its components model--
was good for us.
And it was.
Polymer was very
bad at that moment.
But reminder-- we are
using the [INAUDIBLE] API,
so truth is, the list
of browsers we support
is actually short.
So no problem with Polymer.
At that moment-- no.
We are going to take back
the player components.
How are we going to
code it with Polymer?
We are binding.
So a movie object is
binding to the player
by the controller, which
will bind the movie
to the other subcomponents.
The timing will be
binding to the template
by the control panel.
Our button will fire DOM
native events-- click events.
The control panel
will handle them.
And we'll be able to fire
play and stop events.
And when it receives
those events,
the player will be
able to code directly
the renderer components
play and stop.
So that composition
is more variables,
but it's actually simpler.
Because there is no question
of how things should be done.
You bind elements,
you fire events,
and you code directly
your child components.
And with that composition,
we can reuse the renderer.
So that's what we needed.
So at that moment, we
started a migration process.
I was OK to live
two weeks in a cave
and make the whole
migration and come back.
But Papa-- Dad--
wasn't OK with that.
I think I would have missed him.
So I did that.
We had a components
hierarchy with Angular.
And we started using--
as Polymer components are
standard elements-- we started
changing the last elements
in the hierarchy.
So we did not try to match
the two binding systems.
We did not try to broadcast
the DOM events and the scope.
We just chose polymer
components as DOM elements
in our Angular application.
And we changed, layer by
layer, the whole application.
We reached the
controller and they just
became stateful components
and the routing.
That simple.
Everything's a component.
People who compare the two
frameworks-- AngularDart
and Polymer-- always
miss three things,
which are injection and
services, the scope,
and routing.
And that's because Polymer
is not a framework.
Polymer is just a library.
I'm going to explain
how we replaced them.
About injections and services--
that was actually simple.
Because dependency
injection mechanisms
library of AngularDart
can be reused separately,
so we used it.
And we implemented an inject--
a notation in our code.
So we have an Instill element
which extends the Polymer base
elements.
And in its life cycle, we
have an injection process.
So that's not complicated.
It's the same, actually.
Our implementation
is not perfect
yet because we use Reflection.
But we watch another
system and so on.
About the scope--
in our use cases,
the scope satisfied
three use cases.
There is the communication
between related components,
the subject of the
component model.
So we've already
talked about it.
The internet change tracking,
because sometimes binding
is not enough.
And you want to manipulate
the DOM manually.
And communication between
non-related components.
I will talk about
the two last ones.
About internet change tracking--
there is nothing to say,
actually.
Everything is in the framework.
So the scope watch
inside an element
is replaced by the
property change
mechanisms of the observed
property annotation.
So in that case, if
I change my project,
the project change will
be automatically called
by the framework.
And if I change the title, the
title observer will be called.
The real question was
about communication
between non-related components.
You should have a few
use cases like that one.
If you have a lot,
you have a problem.
But in that example,
the interesting part
is the green one.
I have a ThemeChooser.
And when my user
changes theme, I
want the three previews to
be changed in real time.
So if I use the
previous-- the mechanisms
that I already
talked about I would
have to fire an event until
the application container.
But I don't want my
application container
to be aware of the SIM.
He doesn't care.
He manipulates big components.
He doesn't care
about the SIM system.
So what I want to do is that.
I want to be able to broadcast
a ThemeChangedEvent directly
to the preview.
For [INAUDIBLE] case,
we have an event bus.
We actually use the
package event bus,
which is the label and pub.
We extended it a little bit.
For registering purposes.
So in our ThemeChooser,
we have eventBus.fire(new
ThemeChanged(newStyle)).
That's a true code
of our code base.
And you preview the elements,
we have just a eventBus.listen.
So those elements have
to be as few as possible.
But in that type of use
cases, you have the event bus.
About routing-- we
actually didn't miss it.
You need it.
Like for dependency
injection, you
can use it as a package,
separately of Angular.
But in our case,
we tried to make
Instill the more-- we tried to
make the experience the close
as possible to a
native application.
So we have parts of the
application which are almost
always displayed,
but not always.
And what we would have
to do with AngularDart
is nested views.
But if you asked internet
about nested views,
you will have that
kind of response.
Nested views are complicated
and routing isn't done for that.
So we introduced a
notion of places.
A place contains two things.
The state of the application--
which project I am working on--
and the display state--
which screen, which view,
is displayed?
Which paths are displayed?
And that whole place
is series label.
So we actually used
the history API.
And the goal of
routing, which is
sharing links and manipulating
the browser history-- we
don't need to share links.
It's not relevant for Instill.
But we wanted to be able
to use Next, Previous,
and to make refresh
on the same page.
And with our places, we
are able to sterilize them
and to use the history API.
So that is great for the user.
And that's great, also, for
the developer experience.
Because when you
refresh the application
after changing the code,
it's just the same place.
So as a conclusion, we have
a really great development
environment.
I think everybody here agrees
that Dart tools are great.
The package manager, the
built systems, the IDE.
I'm actually switching from
Eclipse to IntelliJ in Java.
And IntelliJ is really great,
and I'm happy about the plug
in.
It has JavaScript lightness.
You change the code, refresh
your browser, and that's it.
But we have a
productivity enhancement.
Just a tool upgrade with
refactor possibilities,
et cetera.
I actually already felt
that way once with Flex.
Flex was a great framework.
But difference is
here, this is web.
This is not flash.
So that's great.
We are able to use a
JavaScript libraries.
We actually use
perfect-scrollbar in our views.
And we can use web tools.
So we use, actually, SASS,
or CSS, and browsersync.
So when you make modifications,
it's refreshed the browser.
And that's great
for CSS, actually,
because it doesn't
refresh the whole page.
And that's it.
We have the greatest development
environment we never had.
So thank you.
FRANCOIS SAULNIER: Merci.
[APPLAUSE]